jobber Oh 15 and Oh last year with LSU
Heisman Trophy national champion
presumptive number one overall pick but
big cat there have been some breadcrumbs
in recent days it began with Carson
Palmer saying that Joe burrow shouldn't
want to play for the Bengals because the
Bengals aren't trying to win a Super
Bowl standing alone that was a little
bit alarming but then when you follow
that with Jordan Palmer
Carson's brother working directly with
Perot to get him ready for the draft
that becomes a little alarming and then
when Burroughs on Dan Patrick show last
week and burrow had previously said I
want to play for anyone who will pay me
to play for them on DP show he said I
want to play for a team that's committed
to winning it all comes together as what
could be could be a potential power play
the first time since 2004 with Eli
Manning the second time since John Elway
with the Colts when they were in
Baltimore in 1983 that a guy who is
presumed to be the first overall pick in
the draft would try to finagle his way
away from the team that holds that pick
and when you look at those various
little pieces
I think it's obvious he's at least
thinking about whether or not he can
talk his way out of being the next
quarterback of the Bengals and wouldn't
you and wouldn't you that's that's
really the takeaway from this story we
always have these type of stories that
mean it hasn't happened like you said
since Eli Manning but if you're the
Bengals and you even have a rumor of
this story and I think Joe Byrne will go
play wherever he gets drafted and he'll
be a great franchise quarterback and
he'll probably win a Super Bowl I'll say
it right now who probably would have
Superbowl even if it is with the Penn
goals but if you are the Bengals and you
hear these rumors and you see these
stories don't you have just one moment
of introspection and be like hey you
know what like what's wrong with us the
fact that this is even an idea that a
player of Joe burrows caliber could say
I don't want to go here because you guys
don't want to win like if if someone
said that about me if I was the owner or
the GM or the coach of an organization
and someone said that about me I don't
have a big moment where I step back and
say hey we got to figure out what we're
doing and why
is wrong and change everything that
we're doing because you can't have guys
coming to the draft and say yeah I don't
want to go play there because that place
is a joke
yeah but big cat that ship sailed nine
years ago because when Carson Palmer
quit on the Bengals he didn't retire he
quit on the Bengals even though he
didn't come out and say the same things
he said last week it was obvious from
the context his actions and reports that
emerged at the time that he'd had enough
that that's it I've I've reached my
lifetime limit of playing for this
organization and it is well-established
in league circles then Mike Brown the
owner of the team really doesn't care
about winning a Super Bowl he cares
about making as much money as he can
spending as little as he can to increase
the profit margin and that's the
reputation the Bengals have had for
years and Peter King was on earlier this
week the first team he covered out of
college was the Cincinnati Bengals once
he was on an NFL beat he said Mike Brown
will tell Joe burrow go sit and rot like
he did the Carson Palmer
you know if Jason Campbell doesn't break
his collarbone two days before the trade
deadline in 2011 and the Raiders don't
turn around and give up way too much to
get Carson Palmer from the Bengals
there's a chance the guy never would
have played again because Mike Browns
attitude was then and very well maybe
now hey Joe burrow you don't like it
we're drafting you if you don't want to
show up don't show up all right so with
everything you just said maybe Joe Broz
should pull an Eli Manning because it's
just crazy to me that you could have an
NFL franchise and have that attitude and
I understand what you're saying as you
see it all the time with owners they
don't care about winning they just want
to make money but wouldn't a smart
person say hey you know we'll make you
more money winning more games having a
team that people are excited about
having a team that people want to buy
jerseys and go to the games and spend
money and all those things it seems like
that would make sense but Mike Brown
maybe he doesn't have a brain in this
skull and he can't figure that out I
don't know you tell me I don't know that
that they've gone that far down the
chain of logic it's just been a very
simple process throughout the 20 years
I've been doing this that the Bengals
are the outlier that really aren't
interested in
being as good as they can be now they
had five straight playoff appearances
that's great but they I'm on a playoff
game since January of 1991 and you know
a couple of years ago the year the
Broncos won the Super Bowl
it came down to like a week 15 or 16
Monday night game when AJ McCarron was
playing quarterback for the Bengals and
the game went to overtime and if the
Bengals had won that game the complexion
of the postseason in 2015 would have
been very different but for the most
part this has not been a team that we
look at and say this is a high-end
contender that is on its way potentially
to a Super Bowl but look I
and people have pushed back against this
notion on Twitter by reciting the
playoff appearances and the one loss
record over the past 20 years bottom
line is if carson palmer is willing to
put his name to this belief that the
bengals aren't trying to win a Super
Bowl I got no basis for disagreeing with
the guy who was with the team for nearly
a decade and lived it every single day
and played with two teams after that
that he could compare them to the vibe
in Cincinnati so yeah if Joe burrows my
kid I'm trying to work away for the
Dolphins to trade up and get him so he
doesn't have to deal with that question
of being drafted by the Bengals and
maybe sitting out a full year and
reentering the draft cuz I don't think
if push comes to shove Joe burrow is
walking away from nearly 30 million
dollars fully guaranteed and and sitting
out a year and maybe not being the first
overall pick after somebody else emerges
as the presumptive number one in 2021 so
I guess the last question I have for you
Mike about this is is Joe burrow the
type of quarterback that can change the
entire culture of a franchise of a team
I think he is I honestly do you know and
I'm obviously a little biased because
we've had him on our show a couple times
and you know I've had a chance to sit
down with him I just see it in him and
and I've been around a lot of guys where
you just see something special that it
factor where he will be that leader that
galvanizing force for franchise so if
you're Joe burrow Joe burrows dad if
you're saying to yourself hey you know
what the bengals an organization that
isn't committed to winning but they'd
never had a jobber oh and if you believe
in yourself maybe Joe burrow changes all
that be
because they then say we have this guy
we have this huge chip we have a guy who
could be a franchise quarterback
let's build around that let's spend some
money and and that can kind of change
the complexion of how the Bengals do
business possibly but I will say this I
have immense respect for the fact that
you have full and complete transparency
that you essentially can be bought that
you always can be bought oh and I'm your
friend don't come on my show and I'm not
your friend and I won't be your friend
until you come on my show then I'm your
friend ah you you know who benefits from
that policy more than any single person
in this world you're looking right at
him
Mike Florio if Mike Florio wasn't a
friend of mine I would be ripping him to
shred it would be you would have block
me years ago so if you want to criticize
that policy go ahead you just remember
who that helps most and that's Michael P
Florio let me tell you this if this is
how you treat me and I'm your friend
I can act it would be like if I wasn't
your friend I kind of play blocking you
every Friday during the show so a
Schefter a shefter I've been I've been
all up in that business for a long time
with Chef T yeah let's not go down there
this morning there's some fresh
developments in that in that feud that
we don't want to spend any time on on
the show because the audience doesn't
care they do care about this though
Joe burrow has to at least be
contemplating the possibilities and I'll
tell you this and a big cat I am very
leery of pre-draft rumor everybody's got
an agenda everybody's got an angle so
many smoke screens
I rarely traffic in that stuff anymore
but I know for a fact and the only
reason I mention it is because I know it
for a fact
Steven Ross the owner of the Dolphins
wants Joe borough and I assume I don't
know
but I assume Burroughs camp is aware of
that that becomes a factor in this as
well if you know that you can with a
little pressure with a little
awkwardness for the Bengals with a
little that introspection that may cause
them to say why do we want this guy if
he doesn't want to be here I mean that's
a thing you
your quarterback to want to be there
he's got to be all in he's got to be the
team leader he's got to show up early
and stay late he's got to be fully
engaged if he's got any hesitation
that's not good for the team maybe this
is laying the foundation for the
Dolphins to make a deal they got plenty
of draft capital Chris Greer the GM is
said so himself within the past couple
of weeks
make the move up to number one and get
Joe Borough it wouldn't shock me if
that's what borough is hoping for and if
it doesn't happen the Bengals draft him
you make chicken salad or at least you
try to but I think they'd like the
Dolphins to move up to number one and
take him lose so then what happens to -
uh-oh I don't know maybe - it goes to
the Bengals at five
maybe they keep adult for one more year
right keep Andy Dalton for one more year
cheap contract under 20 million dollars
for an adult for one more year let to us
sit on the bench like they did with
Carson Palmer when Jon Kitna was the
starting quarterback and then - is your
guy in 2021 I mean if they keep Andy
Dalton for another year they really are
the dumbest organization that's ever
been created because they put an
adventure danny dalton last year they
said we're moving on from Andy Dalton
and that was like the you know the in
delt was clearly their best quarterback
option last year and they put him on the
bench so I guess that would make perfect
sense so what you just said is is
exactly what's gonna happen because it
is the Bengals so they will trade the
pick take - uh and have Andy Dalton be
the quarterback next year and have
everything be very weird you know will
happen and y'all will somehow win ten
games and everyone will tell themselves
hey maybe Andy Dalton is the answer for
the quarterback for the Cincinnati
Bengals five straight playoff
appearances for Andy Dalton to start his
career with the Bengals and let me just
say one thing before we break for
whatever reason Peter King on this
program and elsewhere I assume has
linked Andy Dalton to the Patriots
enough times that it made me say to
Peter
during a break the other day you're
saying this so much I feel like you know
something he says he doesn't know
anything but how about Andy Dalton is a
New England Patriots next quarterback
what do you think of that I mean
wouldn't it be the ultimate Belichick to
figure out a way to win a Super Bowl
with Andy Dalton it would be incredible
theater to watch that's the that's the
ultimate proof that it's Belichick not
Brady if you can bring in a guy who's
middle-of-the-pack at best and win a
Super Bowl what is that
say about Brady I kind of like the
possibilities I mean we're gonna talk
later in the pro in the program our
draft is predictions of things that will
happen this offseason I just don't think
enough people have have emerged from the
presumption that he's definitely gonna
stay with the Patriots I think that
there's a good chance he won't be and
that would make for a crazy 2020 were
gonna take a break
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports